all to all and welcome to
today's webinar
to quality control is closer to
fulfilling dye or
one leaves
student johannes for four
by spain
[Music]
today's educational webinar is
presented by this contracting similar
group
to get  more information visit
our site at tables
dot for dotcom this webinar
be administrator in spanish we have
only first content and portuguese
before we start
we would like to remind everyone that this
is interactive
we are going to participate by sending as many
questions as you
say anytime you want  during
the presentation to do so simply
sign them up in the ask a few
questions box and click submit we will
answer any questions we
have by the end
of today's presentation there are any problems viewing or
listening to the presentation click the
support tab found on  the
top right of the display window
cor  re for our
problems by clicking on the
ask a question box posted on the
far left of the screen
now features today's speaker
mild détente with air controls
specialist
for new jersey and delaware a lens and
also
particle counting applications specialist for america  latina
me now
to start your presentation
thank you very much johannis again my
name is john lacey
and thank you very much for the introduction
we are going to talk today about the
automation of pharmaceutical quality control
to reduce costs and
improve compliance with 21 cfr part
on the agenda of  Today it will take more or
less 45 minutes and then we will have
time for questions
just so you know
the presentation in the written part is
in English but I will of
course be presenting in Spanish and if
anyone has any questions or doubts in the
meantime they can  request the
questions in the question box well
today we are going to talk about it
the pharmaceutical water quality tests
also about the
environmental monitoring of the clean rooms and
at the end we are going to talk about the
tests of particles inside the
injectable medicines
well
in
this presentation we are going to talk about
how quality control
and its procedures
can  provide problems for
users and how automation can
improve data integrity over the
network reduce opportunities for human error
while saving time and reducing
operating costs in these
procedures
as I speak to you these three issues
are the most common issues we
are facing  and our
pharmaceutical clients are also facing
in the manufacturing factories of
pharmaceuticals and bioparc me ceutical
well first we are going to see the onsets
and trends of pharmaceutical quality control
and data integrity and
the cost of control of them
we are going to  talk about the sda ​​and 21 se
re  part 11 and the errors that are
part of
what happens when people try to
comply with these rules
well a recent report alleges that 79
percent of all warning letters
issued or the sda ​​and these letters are
called the 483
in 2016
site that had  problems with meeting
the integrity of 21 is dealt 11
while many people think
the most common response to a card like this
is king train people or
retrain staff this is
only part of the solution the
problem is not simply that the
workers did not follow the it wanted to
extend to pringles ishares not the
standard operating procedures that
I am going to quote as that p how they are known
by their initials in English it is not
only that the users were not
following this but we want to be
sure that we can prevent
future references  of these problems
any process that automates
quality control and its feces or fish
can potentially reduce  citing the impact
of human error on
data integrity issues but it
can also be
a saving of reducing
technicians time and also ensuring that they
can carry out these peace of mind without
problem in the future
now another report suggests that
a  typical pharmaceutical company that
is making drugs is
spending more or less 40 million
euros per year on quality control and
all the complement that with associated growth
in feedback from customers are
saying data integrity
and internal pressure from  the organization
to reduce the cost of
quality control is also strong each site or
each facility has a
cost center so they often have to
compete with not only
other
competitors in the market but
also sister facilities in
other parts of the world.  world where they
can sometimes lose the product
to be transferred to another part of the world
because it is  In another facility, they are
saving more money.
Well, the idea
has issued an initiative in the past,
which dates back to 2004, which is the ATE process,
which is the process analytical technologies initiative,
and what does it
mean
that the procedures in the industry
were mostly processes?  manual and
time-consuming to carry
out these processes in the spirit
of
his initiative on the part users
should consider moving away from just
manual lab based testing
to online
quality control instrumentation for example many
Companies have cared
for online water quality systems for pure water
or water for injection which is known as
their initials in English wifi
in the water rings but they many
companies still use the
manual systems where you have to go to each point
of use
and  collect a hand sample and then
take it to an instrument in the
laboratory to run the hand samples
while these instruments are
online you can validate the
instruments online and avoid all these manual processes
and at the same time
and meet the requirements of the
european US pharmacopoeias
etc.
this type of automation process
can reduce the amount you are
spending on tests  laboratory and
also have more
precise and faster answers,
for example in 2019
we are seeing here the numbers have already improved a
bit but these are the
numbers of the 483 casing of the sda ​​issued
to pharmaceutical companies citing that there
were problems with the
data integrity as we can see in 2015 and
2016 the numbers
were very high but the idea is
pushing this idea from the
ate initiative to reduce in these
letters and put the systems automate
the systems and put them more online
but globally as we can  see more
almost 50% of the letters issued by the
sda ​​have to do with integrity  data
good human error
a study
carried out by the laboratory
called in two neighborhoods of quickly
showed that there is more than 20
percent variability in the results
among 16 quality control technicians
when they are
carrying out the  Even
that manual,
clearly the manual is the one that can
be improved by retraining the technicians,
but since we are human and we can have
errors, it can be Monday morning,
for example, where the possibility of
making errors is more,
but
and a variability in the results
suggests that the process  The manual by
itself is not robust enough to be able to
deliver the required levels
of quality control because there is
variability from operator to
operator
whereas the
technical specifications of the
quality control instrumentation may be
equivalent when you are attempting
better quality control.
quality control and light teams should
be looking for a level of
self  clarification in the intermediation to
make it that the quality control tests
are much more robust and can
be repeated, for example,
a common source of errors
is in the quality control is the
preparation of the samples an
instrument that can automate
automate in the samples  and its
preparation
can improve the reproduction
of civility bruce of the
and make it more robust
in the quality control tests and
as we can see in this
figure all
the technicians who are following the s&p the
same but we can see that there is a
variation  very big
in
the water quality test
we are going to take a look at this part
where most of the companies that
manufacture injectable medicines they
need a system of water for
injection or
pure water to be able to manufacture the
medicines and products
and
the criteria and the  The most critical quality
for
the system of pure water and water for
injection are four parts according to
the DEA inorganic materials.  organic ales
within the water also toxins
and microbes today we are going to focus on
tc which is all organic carbon which is
known as its letters in english theo i know
but in spanish it is total organic carbon
and this is one of the criteria that
is  the one that needs to be fulfilled to be able
to release its water to be able to manufacture
the medicines not in the pharmacopoeia esp
6-4 three parties and the 645 in those
chapters 6 4 or 5 for
[Music]
I know and conductivity you have to comply
with these to  to release your
products
there are online analyzers such as the pp
700 the beckman coulter instrument can
be validated to fully meet
usp 6 43 16 45 and these are two
key attributes to be able to
release your water
in the past there have been many tests with
who with  who the technicians had to work on
in the column on the left are that they
are all the lists of characteristics
and tests that they had to run on for
toxins of calcium sulfate and so
on in
the f  ed has already said look that you have to
change these to make it easier
so in the past they have removed
one of these tests but others for
example calcium only lacked chlorine ammonium
co2 and oxidizable substances and they have
changed it to usp 643 it seems 12 and 6  45
for conductivity
there are two ways to run
tests
what the fed is suggesting according to its
initiative of the pp
the way to run the tests online
or almost in real time because
online it normally takes six to seven
minutes to run this test of 64 36
45 online there are several several
strong points for example it can be validated and
work with high purity water it can
have a continuous measurement there is no need to
touch the sample
also there is no way to contaminate the
sample because it stays inside the
water system without being
exposed  to the environment we are also
measuring what is in its own environment, that is,
within the hoses and pipes of
the water system, they are also the
true water levels  there is no one
influencing we can also have
immediate or almost immediate data results
as it takes less than six
minutes and we can
have conductivity and temperature results in
addition to 12 but the lack
one of the points that are not strong is
that they have a limited range of  a pp
I see part per million
2000 ppp
in the other hand we have a
laboratory instrument of 12
has its strengths that is it can
evaluate all waters that is
sterile water water for injection pure
water up to very dirty water like what is used
in  cleaning validation for example
when cleaning a container
to confirm that it is clean to be
able to manufacture more products at a
future time
can be done with a
tea analyzer instrument or for example from the
laboratory several samples can be analyzed
using an autosampler  or other
examples is also independent of
conductivity but
has some points that are more
laborious points for  example because
reagents are needed for a
benchtop instrument and a gas to carry them to be
able to carry out the measurements
also
when users or technicians go
to take a manual sample a long
time they can contaminate the
sample if they are touching the
container inlet also the
container is open when they are
filling the bottle and may have
contamination from the environment also
the data is delayed because you have to
wait until all the samples
are run and also to track
the sample protocols it may take
a while  and also cause confusion problems
beckman coulter has an
instrument called the pad 700 in we have
stolen the name pad from the initiative
behind it is analytical technology
to be able to put this instrument
online is different than a
laboratory instrument because it is not needed
reagents and requires
manual setup for each
sample which  What happens is that the instrument receives
water from the water system using a
tube that comes out of the central hose
that enters the instrument every six
minutes takes a sample after a
rinse takes a sample and performs
a pure water or water analysis
of a water for in jackson
automates the testing protocol and only
requires a calibration once every 12
months
the calibration and debilitate
testing system is automated so it does not
require any
manual influence and does not need any
operator
[Music]
to get in with the system  and also all
the reports are pass fail so
all the data is automatically
generated
and managed by the instrument it does
all the calculations to determine
what is the connectivity and sends this
data directly to a system where you
can archive the data and the connection
it can be 4 to 20 thousand jams or also
morbid over ethernet
this is
a copy of the screen for example it gives
all
the pa list  sos that needs to be done
to carry out a weak site
for an instrument a tve analyzer
as you can see in the first position
the bottle of reactive water is put, which
is a blank and in the third position
the standard of 500 parts per
billion sucre of sucrose and in the
fourth it is 500 parts per billion of
quignon I sell at 1 421 na in bottle 3
an organic that is easy to oxidize and
in position 4 it is an organic that is
difficult to oxidize
shows the process where  place the
bottles so that the technicians cannot completely
confuse
these bottles
in
this photo we can see this is a
real installation where we have the
feuse instrument that is set up
right next to the water system
the water is entering on the right hand side and
leaving  below the right hand
to the drain or
this is an ultra pure water system a
loop or a ring where it is every six
minutes is taking samples and
processing the samples as we can see
there is only  to get the system up
and running and you don't need someone to go there to
monitor it if there is a problem with one of
the readings or if the water exceeds the
teo 500v limit an
electronic message was sent directly to the
system which may be monitoring the
results  so someone can go to
the water system to determine why it
is exceeding the limit
now the difference like here we can
see
the difference between a manual system
versus an automated system in the
blue dots these are for example at
the bottom you can see we are
seeing days and on the
left side this is the limit
of tc numbers in terms of parts per
million
ok the limit is 500 parts per billion
now if I am the technician and I go every
three days I don't go if day number one  it's
monday i go monday at 10 in the morning he
took a manual sample and then
wednesday wednesday then friday and
then the following monday if i
take a manual sample and i take the
mix m  our manual the analyzer 16
I go to the laboratory process everything seems
fine everything below 500 tv but an
automated system where it does not need the
influence of the technician or a
human being and is taking a sample every six minutes
we can see that on
Thursday we have a  rise
of particles and oxidizable particles, not of tea, that is,
where it exceeds the 500 dpi limit, there was
a problem on that shitty day of
Thursday, if I have a human process, I
will not realize that
this is going to affect my quality of  my
product and I continue manufacturing
but
and following the ph initiative of the sda
we do not want to see every minute that is
happening to be able to control the quality
now on that day on thursday
I would have received a message saying
look at everything look at what we are
having a problem because
it exceeded the teo, the 500 pv is exceeded, it is the limit and
I could have identified what the
problem was and how I can solve it,
that is, the advantage of automatic  tizar
and quality control
now in this instrument that we have
for example the pad 700
every time I record
a test and perform a test
after finishing it I sent it directly from the
instrument to a place where it is
and saving all the results
in the fight emphasizes  that according to 21 csr
part 11 the rules apply to
historical data not where you are
keeping the historical data where
that is where we have to put a lot of
emphasis
the danger with online systems is that
they archive everything on the instrument
itself and are not  sending this to a
place that is 21 cfr party 11 the
accomplice traditionally the data from
one of god's analyzers
yes they
are putting together storing in a
validated monitoring and
systems system where you can archive everything in
one system what we call
the system  scada no, it is a system of
supervision and control of data
acquired
ok our instrument can be
confirmed everything files in the inst  ment
but at the same time it sends
all the results to another client system
ok also the programs that have to
do with
clean rooms and clean rooms environmental control program
is where
we also work
undefeated in
cutter between 30 to 50 trillion  microbes
are on top of and inside human beings
and humans human beings we
shed more than 30 thousand
skin cells every hour or fraction or
approximately 3.6 kilos of
skin cells per year
of course the gmp mandates that the
quality control conditions of the
air in the production of
biopharmaceuticals in clean rooms
must be following a standard but
the real danger is that
human microbes are there inside the
clean rooms as we release
so much we
are the carriers of
problems
and microbial return inside  of these
clean rooms this is one reason why
we want a matte automate
for example m  There are many processes for which
human beings are not interfering or
we are not introducing
microbial
pollution so we cannot
necessarily manually count the
particles and we use
particle counters or they are also
said to be particle meters
we are using these to be able to
determine the  amount of
microbial and polishing contamination inside the
clean rooms
challenges of monitoring
the environment inside the clean rooms
to the expectations of the
government branches that are in charge of reebok
all like the pharmaceutical industry on
top of that the responsibility of
the microbial team of microbial
of quality control they have to
be working
and confirming that everything is fine so
that the people and the technicians in the
production room can carry
out their work well and safely
and we have spoken with many many
managers who are in charge of
evaluating the  environmental monitoring
in the facilities  nes across the
world we've found that they're
seeing a trend where
the charge of doing all the
environmental monitoring
of this production is increasing and it's getting out of
the hands of him
from the quality control team
and passing it on to
[Music]
professionals.  of the production area
for two reasons
the first reason is that it
is expensive to have microbiology technicians
and pay them just to carry out
the common daily tasks that can be
done by someone else and the second is
that it reduces the number of people that
are coming into the production area.  clean rooms
i.e. outsiders
entering a controlled location so it
can reduce potential contamination
to products but
the production team does not have the
same level of knowledge about
typical
and routine monitoring of
the environment within a clean room  not
necessarily not and that creates several
other challenges
well a problem that we
have heard that customers  s they are
facing is the way it
is a manual system of making the sample
and also configuring the system point
1 normally we have to be sure
that we are using the s&p not the
standard operating procedure the
correct one and also the user has to
read and understand it is  difficult sometimes
because you have new technicians or you have
technicians who are
doing these procedures on a
daily basis so many times they ignore
what it says
on the s&p because they think they
have it memorized
andthen the
user typically has to
touch not on a touch screen that
they  they have to write the machine
the name of the sample the local and
also have to configure the
instrument
number 3 they have to
collect the data and then they have
to organize them after the end of the
day sometimes it has a a label not a
receipt that has  four ten fifteen
meters in size and they have to
cut the strain the organize them and in
everything for all the  As our samples
that they have made
in point number 4 they have to
add the comments in all the
physical labels then manually
they have to take a look at the
results and confirm that there were no
alert and action levels, that is,
they do not have alarms  what to
photocopy you are
making a copy of
a pdf of these
and after that another step where you
have to manually transcribe the
results to the official record
what
and then you have to take the time of
another person to confirm that the
person who entered it manually did not
enter  ok
and then the last person has to
manually review and approve it as
we can see these are 6 or 7 points or
steps where with human beings we can
have errors
ok
in sda in 2018 had a paper on
them published a paper on 21 cfr
part 11 that  He talks about
data integrity and complying with the cmp and they talked about
what we call alcoba
and alcoba means they are initials to
alcoa sig  It means that the record has to
be attributable legible recorded at the same time it
has to be
original and it has to be accurate
and we are going to describe all of these
we are talking about for example in the
challenge we have with recording
all the readings and tests in the
center of a clean room
We have just launched a
tool that is completely alcohol compliant
and it is something that our
clients were wanting,
for example
in attributable alcohol. We have
placed within our tool
the active directory active directory
means that
in the password and the login data
of the users who  they use to
access their company computer not and their
email for example they
also use the same great
credentials and passwords to access
the particle counter in our
instrument all users are
required to access the instrument we
call metro mont 3402
with their name  username and
password c  credentials can be controlled
locally by the instrument or through
the IT section they do not
use the dap which is the active
directory of microsoft and that means
they use the same credentials to
access the instrument and this records
all configuration changes of the instrument
instrument that the user has made, it
can be attributed that the user accessed the
instrument to what now if they did it
remotely or through a web browser,
for example, or if they used the
instrument itself
in the bedroom, it means readability,
that means that the notes  They are notes
that the user entered trans and that can
be observations, for example, on the
screen it is placed directly in the
electronic record, for example, if the
user is working and performing an
air sample not inside a
clean room and exceeds the limit in number
of particles has to be a reason
maybe someone opened a door or
someone passed the user then
this user can  e attribute
this information directly to the
record in real time so
that it is within electronic recess and
the notes can be
mandatory optional and once it is
entered, no data can be removed or deleted
and you can never remove it from
the comments
and it can also be  You can put a drop down no
the possibility is it can be the five
more
and more typical reasons you can put it
so that there is a menu where you
select the user or the user can
manually enter the comments
in the contemporary
and original bedroom cee  where they are
reviewing and approving the electronic record
they have that the accountant
automatically created
the
original electronic record and immediately
after finishing the sample once
it is fulfilled
in all the samples of the day it can be
reviewed and approved either in the instrument
or by accessing it
from another's desk from the manager's office they
can access the instrument the
analogy  to review the data and have
an electronic signature other than the sign
center and at the same time created the
record with the electronic signature
within the record to export directly
from the accountant via the internet or via Wi-Fi
is created within the record itself
also shows that you already accept
had the access of the  user
administrator access or access officer
everything and gave the ok
the manager can access it and at the same time
while the user is performing
the additional samples
the manager can access the
instrument remotely
the an and the eye of the car one shows that
the electronic records with
the user id and
the s&p version not just to remind you ethiopian
means in english
the standard operating procedure
the electronic record can accept
remotely also filter it export
it via pdf or excel pdf is a
way of
acceptable about 21 cfr  matches
to be attributed and original the record
must contain the name of the  ethiopian
and version number in a username
the number of backs local time now
settings etc.
no and if there was an alarm or not
and also in the alcove it says taxi network or
precision there is no manual data
within the settings and i don't center anything
manually  in terms of writing it in
the recipe what can be improved the
precision and there is no manual data for
the user's written not by hand and they are
following the s open
also precision the pf is controlled
by the administrator is fully
confirmed within the instrument in the
3400 new as employees as you can
see the new version of the new model
we can see that we can place
a map of the place and also have a
list of all the points where the
user has to take a measurement and
the ethiopian is controlled by the
administrator through  of all the
instruments
and also accurate decision on the aud
/ or not in the auditorium or
audit record we have all the information  ation
about who has access to the instrument
started
to carry out the test etc. here
now started at now finished he
who was the user etc. records
everything
and can also be filtered by date
reports can be managed by date
local time etc
and when finished we have
and the test to determine the number of
products pardon number of particles
within a final product of an
injectable medication
this is
to be a little different because we can
determine it through particles per
ml in serums for example or per
container or particles within  a
syringe for example so this can be
complex but to carry out
usp 7 or 8 8 for injectables 787 of the
usp to inject in
small volumes or in usp 789 for
ophthalmic we have an
instrument called
el jaya 9703  blogs where this
tool automates everything so that the
user only has to enter a minimum
number of data and the
basic tool  ically it runs the sample in the
test by itself
for example there is a drop down here where
the user can select
he can select which is the product
to go to carry out and
automatically electronically he can
review it to test it after each
test
at the end  you can put your notes and put it
on a waiting list where the manager
can access all the results from his office
and give the ok you can
file everything in accordance with alcoa and
place the texts so that it is
part of the record
in conclusion what we are
Saying is that reconsidering is not the
solution, for example in a
typical training if someone here in the front
training some people here are
sleeping others are working some if they
graduated
and partially understood the subject and
other people were yes confirming
that they understand everything but
reconsidering not  going to fix the
problem is only treating the symptoms
of the problem and is not curing the
disease what we are
advising is for the future solution is
to automate the process and it is called
robust through its automation
we want to eliminate all
possibilities of human errors to
reduce costs also
again my name is john leahy you
can ask questions or doubts
through my email jrr
lh and at accion dotcom
as of course spanish and i also
speak english and portuguese and you can
request your questions in any
certain three languages ​​now if anyone
has questions or hans
and already
informative version on the web we have
many  questions, however, with
time, so I will close and here with
a selection
and then we will share with
people the answers by mail
because what we have I think with little
boxes although it is the first project the
first question is from Juan Carlos are
these an option  warning letters
were issued upon conducting audits and
discovering situations  s with manual processes
if most of these
warning letters were issued after
audits have been performed no and
discover discovered problems no and
that a every problem there is
the person the auditor has to
identify what the problem is what was
the cause of the problem  problem what they
want that was the cause of the problem and
also how they can fix the
problem so with a
lot like more than 50 percent of
the time the problems are because of
a manual system where people didn't
follow the protocols sp
a  Question about this disk with this
Argentinian,
how does the equipment send the data to
the Wi-Fi client server?
Well, that's a very good question if
each instrument, depending on when it was
developed, has its way of
communication
to the communication media of the
instrument. Part 700 is only by
cable.  no and this is because normally
this is these tea instruments or you
are in a room of water in a  place that
is far not
from the factory or in another place so
this is the cable no but the
meter analyzers have 3400 they
can or connect with tcp/ip no or
ethernet
or also via wifi all
beckman instruments
particle counter coulter 3,402 they all
come with wifi and many times what
happens is that if there is no wifi in the place
as soon as it connects to wifi
it connects to the system and updates
all the records and sends all the
resources to
me  I think we have the time for
scarier than
stevia then
although the question is if he can
monitor chlorine at two parts per million
also on the same analyzer
no sorry the instrument for 700
can you confirm the tvc levels
temperature and conductivity  and that's
it, another instrument is needed to measure
chlorine
and I think the question could be if
rubén will be available later, more
link
jon
can use
this type of network system  continuous monitoring
I have to follow it wing jimenez
if the instrument can be used
continuously just keep a few things
in mind not one has three batteries and
depending on the flow rate of the instrument
if the 21.3 liters per minute 50 liters
per minute 100 liters per minute is
you can run the instrument using
batteries or if it is connected to
electricity it can be monitored 24
hours there is no problem
and it can be used continuously and you
only have to calibrate it once a year
later we will send them later
but orozco the last  ask a
question the measurement of food of the day
without temperature compensation is very
very good question
cesar the conductivity measurement of the
para 300 can be put with or without
temperature compensation it depends on
what the user requires no but there is a little
box where you
can select them  and with or without
compensation
ok
although with your time and your important
research with us it
will be the uers po  r underwrite
today's educational transition and before i go i
would like to thank mainly
everyone in the audience for joining us
ask two questions that we didn't have
time for today and those that came up
during order to order will be
addressed by portion ok through
information  contact you provided at
the time of registration this webinar
can be viewed has requested up to 6
months from the date it is live so
something like January 2017
bruce accepted via email
when available for
playback we
also recommend that you share this
email with your  colleagues who
may have missed the event said
dewey ok so until next time
thank you greetings michelle who is
coordinating and thank you all and
thank you very much